欢迎你学习白泽国际站运营实战系统课
同学们,这一节课我们来讲一下关键词的分类分组的一个法则
怎么样去对关键词进行有效分类更有利于我们后期进行推广
或者是说在表格中有效的管理关键词
我们关键词简单的分为四个小类
比如说第一个是行业词,第二个是核心词,第三个是精准词
第四个就是长尾词
那么这四个分组呢
它并没有一个非常非常清晰的一个界线
它有一些词是介于精准词跟核心词之间的
有些行业词就是你的核心词
所以说它们是没有绝对的非常清晰的界线的
这个也要看行业而定
不同的行业会有不同的类型
所以我们没有必要纠结
它到底归属于哪个
词类
我们只需要大概知道它的
分类以及我们能够
知道怎样去灵活的应用这些关键词就可以了
首先第一个就是行业词
什么是行业词呢
比如说一级类目的词
比如说衣服
手机
还有包包
这些都是行业词
这些基本都是一级
类目二级类目的词
基本就是行业词
很多时候
二级类目的词很有可能就是产品的核心词
什么是产品的核心词
比如说
我说的
T恤
是一个产品核心词
卫衣也是一个产品的核心词
因为你这里的行业词下来衣服
衣服对应的是不是
细分的品类
T恤位移
还有很多很多的品类
那么你手机分下来的时候
核心词是不是
安卓手机
还有苹果手机
苹果手机
是不是还可以分就是智能手机
是不是这些都是核心词
这些都可以作为词根去拓展
你的一些相关的关键词
精准词是怎么样分类的呢
首先我们要记住一句话
一定要记住这句话
精准词就是等于
能够表达出客户需求的
关键词
能够表达出客户需求的关键词
比如说
我T恤
产品
是不是
核心词
那么精准词就是它的属性
属性词
核心词
就是等于精准词
那么属性词里面可能会有
A属性可能会有B属性
可能会有C属性
那么
他这些属性都能够表达出客户对
T恤的
某一种需求比如说
客户搜索
黑色的
棉T恤
是不是能够表达出
比较明确的客户需求
他一定是想要黑色的
而且他这个T恤是棉的
是不是比较精准
还有另一种就是
比如说他收
黑色的棉
蓝T恤
是不是更加
能够表达出
客户的需求
是不是能够表达出客户的需求
如果客户收这个词
核心词比如说
客户只收T恤
那么你知道客户
喜欢的是哪种T恤吗
那
这是不是他的需求不明确
如果客户只收手机这个词
那么是不是
他的需求不明确
你不知道他要
哪一种手机
你也不知道他是要智能手机
还是
苹果手机
还是安卓手机
还是什么内存的手机
如果比如说你搜索
内存
128G的黑色
安卓手机
是不是他需求更加明确
或者是他再加一个品牌
是不是他需求非常明确
那么这种就是
我们所说的精准词
那么长尾词呢其实就是精准词的
衍生
也是能够非常非常精准的表达出
客户的一个需求的
比如说
精准词可能是
一个属性加
加一个核心词
或者是两个属性加
一个核心词
那么长尾词很有可能就是多个
属性
加核心词
属性加核心词
就是长尾词
那么长尾词的特点就是它的
组合方式可能是三到
五个
或者是八个
关键词
组合出来的词
就是长尾词
它的长度
相对来说
比较
长一点点
但是精准词的话可能就是两个词
或者是三个词
也可能是精准词
所以说
他们之间没有绝对的
一个非常清晰的界限
这个的话就是看你个人
对这些词性的理解
然后去应用
最后面我们来讲一下
哪一种词转化是最高的
精准词转化是最高的
长尾词转化也是很高
但是呢
缺点长尾词就是流量太少了
流量少
也就是说他能够
曝光点击的
人很少
所以说这个词
他得到的
总的转化会也会比较少
虽然说转化高但是他的量少
这个词
精准词
他的流量是相对来说比较
大的
同时呢也是相对稳定的
那么他的转化也是比较高的因为我们
客户在搜索的时候
搜索这些词我们就知道
他需要哪些产品
那么我们只要把这些精准词跟他所要的这些产品
精准匹配了那么他转化率是会比较高的
核心词跟行业大词
基本都是
转化比较
第一的
通常比如说
精准词可能要15个点击就来一个询盘是吧
那么长尾词可能就是
一个点击一个询盘或者是
5个点击一个询盘
那么如果是行业词可能会20
到30
才来一个询盘
甚至可能
40到50都没有询盘的都有可能
所以说这个行业词
你一定要慎重的去
使用
你可以用
但是
推广的时候一定不要
开始推进行业词
不然你会发现都只会
花钱
没有藏出
那么核心词的话可能就是
20个
到25个
点击才会来一个选盘
所以说
我们在
推广的时候
你要选词
从哪个维度切入呢
肯定是先从
精准词进行切入
再到
核心词跟长尾词
这些去
进行一个
推广
千万不要一开始就推这行业大词
而且你要做的是
推广的时候
提前
停币
行业词
因为这些行业词会
快速
消耗你的
直动车的预算
这些行业词的话
它的一个流量是非常非常大的
而且它的需求是不明确的
所以说
客户一收
在
首页一收出来的时候发现
你的很多产品
都不符合它的需求的
它可能点进去看
它就跳出来
跳出来的话那么钱也花了
但是你没有得到询盘
这就是一个关键词分组分类的一个法则
希望能够
帮助你更清晰的去了解这些词的分类
在后期主标题
以及
在
推广的时候能够有更加清晰的思路
最后面
叮嘱大家就是
一定要记住这个精准词
的一个
核心的概念
它是
能够
表达出客户的
需求的
能够明确出客户的需求的
最后面我们来
到后台去
看一下
比如说我收一个词
T恤这个词
我收这个词是不是会
出现非常非常多种类的T恤是不是
会出现非常多种类的T恤
如果客户收这个词的时候是不是
你会发现客户需要的T恤
但是他
没有告诉你他要什么样的T恤
他是不是就会在这里找
如果你的款式非常好
非常吸引他的话
是不是你就能够被他点击
如果你的款式是非常不符合当下市场需求的
是不是这个词就会导致你的
店铺里面出现高曝光没有点击的情况
那么这个时候你就要去看
这个是不是大词
如果这个是大词的话
你是不是去测试一下
你的产品的主图是不是
能够更加满足当下的市场需求
比如说我在这个词的基础上加上属性词
在前面加属性词
比如说我是棉的
棉的男式的T恤
刚才收T恤的话很有可能有女式的T恤
那么我在前面加
我要空白的
黑色的
棉男式T恤
你看我这个词是不是能够
至少能够表达出
客户的部分需求了
比如说黑色的是他需求的
棉的
蓝的
空白的
这些都能够
有效的表达出客户的部分需求
那么这样收出来的产品是不是他肯定会
优先看黑色有黑色的
而且是蓝色的
空白的为主
你看这些比如说蓝色
这些没有黑色是吧
可能是不是
这种你看
这种是不是
这种这些是不是更加符合他的需求
有可能就是更加符合他的需求
所以说你在
产品分析的时候就看
如果你被收的是这个词的时候
那么你是不是要去
看一下你的产品
来这里收一下
跟
同行这些自然排名很好的产品是不是
比较一致的款式
因为这个词在这里能够
有排名在
自然排名前面比较好的说明这些
产品
都是能够
被
买家
点击比较多的产品
而且
询盘或者是咨询
订单量
相对来比较好的产品
才能排在前面
所以说你要参考这些款式
去看
你就知道你自己的款式行不行
或者是是不是满足市场
的需求了
这就是我们判断关键词的一些
基本的标准
希望这些思路能够帮助你更好的去理清
这些关键词的一个
表达和关键词的应用
我们这节课就先讲到这里
下节课再见